person in it and then the universe
passes through various epics where
certain of those species are more
important than in other times species
come and species go and we're dealing
with some kind of fossil
Relic which is a non-trivial one because
it's what makes us up
can you explain how the universe expands
and what's meant by it
contrary to
a popular view it's true that on large
scales the universe around us is
expanding
but it is not expanding here in this row
it's in effectively a state of
equilibrium
and so and galaxies and other such
things form
there is no expansion associated with
that this is a good thing otherwise we
would all be getting fatter because in
the Universal expansion but uh
on the large scales very large scales
there's an expansion the expansion is
characterized by a rate of expansion
it's called the Hubble parameter I'm
sure you've heard of it which is
basically just the expansion rate of the
universe but you can also think of it as
spatially
dependent and so in our region of the
universe
our galaxy here
is effectively
no uniform
expansion or contraction there is a an
equilibrium it's not a true equilibrium
because everything is always changing in
time it's just a question of how slowly
or how fast it's changing
but
um
anyway dynamical Universe uh and now I'm
losing the threat of where we were
trying to go basically because I was
going someplace I was trying to give you
a way of looking at the universe that is
actually not standard but if I like to
look around me which if I can I will
this is a uh undergraduate student who's
working with me
this is density Against Time showing the
thermal history of the universe as it
starts at the beginning and goes through
various phases I know you're going to
ask this question later but I thought
thanks for arranging my Prof
and here were four points about what we
were going to do she's still engaged
with this with me and one of them is the
H naught tension which has gotten a lot
of press recently because from the
cosmic microwave background which is
this really high Precision thing that
I've been very much engaged with
throughout my entire career
uh we get a certain value of how rapidly
on large scales the universe is
expanding on average
and then there are other claims using
things like Supernova and stars of a
specific form that the value is
different in the
quite in general Cosmic neighborhood
around us this is called the H naught
tension the expansion rate tension and
it's the number of meetings about this
is enormous around the world and the
issue is whether it's a systematic
effect of not understanding the data
well enough or whether there is some new
profound thing associated with something
that happened relatively late
that cause this expansion to change
we already know that the expansion is
changing in fact that was part of the
great discovery of What's called the
dark energy
but it may be that there is a different
expansion
in the area around us
out to a fairly large distance and then
on even larger distances so this is a
puzzle and why did I do this I was just
trying to say that there is a simple way
of thinking about
the evolution of the universe as long as
you
add
position as well as time into how you
think about it and that it's
inhomogeneous and that it's the same
basic language but it is rarely used
that way in the subject which uh
one of my missions even with
undergraduates is to teach that way of
looking at things
what is dark energy
dark energy
well it
emerged as
so-called Einstein's cosmological
constant and
back in 1917 or so
uh
the observations were such that there
was no indication a that there was
clearly external galaxies and so it
seemed like the stars and structure they
were just buzzing around us so that on
average it was an equilibrium situation
and so yet when you take the laws of
gravity Einstein's theory and curiously
enough
um
it would either contract or expand
automatically the contraction is called
gravitational instability and it's the
way we understand how structure formed
in the universe it's the gravitational
instability theory of the formation of
structure
and so he said well you know maybe the
data is going to enforce me so I'm going
to put in a term
which the theory allowed
and uh it's called the cosmological
constant and then uh about a decade
later or so somebody proved that that
theory is unstable as well
and uh and Hubble discovered the
expansion of the universe by looking at
galaxies nearby and how they were moving
away
and um and Einstein you know this uh
famous statement of Einstein's that uh
it was the biggest blunder he never
apparently actually said that and it
wasn't a blunder it's at sort of the
heart of much of our thinking because
one way of thinking about it is that
it's the um
energy intensity of the vacuum and all
right going back to the word vacuum so
when I write it
I often use row as density many people
use Rover density sub vac
as if that's an obvious thing vacuum
energy except that as I said earlier in
this uh
in this uh of pre thought flow is that
um
the vacuum is fundamentally deformed
it's deformed by the expansion of the
universe is formed by structure deformed
by structures in the universe so vacuum
is not actually
um this pristine thing that people think
about anyway the bottom line is that
that was the original Lambda and it was
embraced by if I won't go into the full
history of this uh but it would rise up
and go down and rise up and go down in
terms of its stock if you like go vote
whether people were interested in it uh
it kind of got resurrected for a few
reasons around the mid 80s
and that's when I was I thought it was
you know a great idea why because uh
as well as matter and radiation
uh
the universe can have curvature I mean
in fact it's always got curvature on
small scales that's what
causes the matter to concentrate anyway
the basic point is that there was this
first indication for me that you needed
something akin to a Lambda the reason I
uh of going back to the threat of
thought there uh curving the Universe on
average on large scales and yet having
small fluctuations on smaller skills and
we had evidence for that anyway the
basic point is you have to have this
large-scale curvature if you're going to
have what is called an open or closed
Universe uh whether it's curve
up like a sphere or curve down like a
saddle uh that was you know what people
mostly thought about whereas the vacuum
energy density
is something that's constant in scale
independent or at least that's the view
uh
so then the other dilemma occurred well
how can it be as small as it would need
to be to make a universe like ours
and that continues to be a huge mystery
because if you count
the the amount of energy density that
you think is in the vacuum
it would depend upon the Planck energy
scale in fact it would go like the
fourth power which is a huge huge number
like nothing that we have ever seen
except the key element here is that you
don't apparently get to observe that you
only get to observe differences or
changes
and so maybe it can all be well
understood that way
but uh
anyway so I liked Lambda
I liked it as a extension Beyond
um just dark matter
and uh and baryons which are the stuff
that we're made of
uh and uh
and so it became part of my kind of
standard thing and then
we were dealing with two kinds of data
Cosmic microwave background as it was
emerging fluctuations that emerge from
the universe around
380 000 years after the so-called Big
Bang uh
and that's like 13.8 billion years ago
um
so that was giving us valuable
information it's since filled in
brilliantly but you know as it emerged
uh it was giving us an indication but
you had we had to add large-scale
structure to that the spatial
inhomogeneity on large scales of the
universe in order to say it looks like
Lambda is pretty good
and we did
and then so that was microwave
background and um
and uh
large-scale structure observations uh
then another set of groups they were
looking at Supernova and they were
developing something curiously enough
it's called the Hubble diagram where
it's Hubble parameter is a function of
time and uh if you have an ordinary
Universe without any Lambda it would
have a certain shape and with Lambda it
has a different shape and so
after
some stops and starts uh it emerged that
that looked like it was also indicating
accelerated expansion and that's the one
that uh
sort of
became the popular way of understanding
of how this emerged but in the microwave
background large-scale structure we're
right there as the underfinning of this
whole story and then there's another
experiment that I was involved in is
called boomerang
um
it was a microwave background experiment
called Boomerang because you launched
from the
uh Antarctica
and the prevailing winds at the top of
the atmosphere caused the balloon to go
around and around and around and so you
get lots of data
and it was really the thing that sold
the vast community in particular the
particle theorists on that you have to
take this extremely seriously it's like
uh that that that's clearly the answer
then the issue is what is the nature of
this
so-called Dark Energy I mean what does
it mean to say an energy is dark for
that matter
this is not this is a bit of a joke for
why do we call it dark matter
and why since matter and energy are
intimately related
why do we have this stupid label but we
do that in this subject there's stupid
labels all over the place some actually
quite clever but you know up down
strange charm is is particle theory
right so if you know there's a little
Whimsy that does occur but Dark Energy
really doesn't convey the information
it's actually uh
uh potential energy density that at the
moment we observe only through its
impact on the expansion of the universe
and not uh in any direct experimental
way the hope is that we will be able to
and so you know billions and dollars
actually have been put into experiments
that give huge amounts of astronomical
information but one of their primary
result was to learn more about the dark
energy which you cannot learn
from observations on the earth in the
lab it is really something writ large in
the ultra large scale Dynamics in the
universe anyway it emerged as being an
ingredient and as time went on it got uh
the the observational evidence got
stronger and stronger and stronger that
that was it and so there were two
aspects to this one is is it just a
uniform potential energy density so that
everywhere including in this row there
would be
this uh
uniform energy density that's sitting
there you wouldn't really be feeling it
but if it could it would try and expand
you it's just that the other forces are
so strong that that doesn't happen
um anyway so there's uh uh this kind of
uniform energy dense today that uh we
think is you know all pervasive but the
evidence we have a fora is on very large
scales so then the question is does it
change in time and why is that
interesting it's because it says it
might not just be potential energy it
might also have a kinetic component you
know there are two types when you learn
physics in school there is potential
energy and kinetic energy and so what is
the kinetic energy amount of the dark
associated with the dark energy so this
is a blazing question and as I said
we're trying very hard to determine
whether or not that's needed at the
moment it isn't you just watched a clip
from the theories of everything channel
for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy